healthcare-associated infections or H
AIS are infections you may get in a
healthcare facility while you are
receiving treatment for a different
condition bacteria such as
methicillin-resistant Staphylococcus
aureus also known as MRSA Enterococcus
species and Clostridium difficile or c
diff are frequently the cause of
healthcare associated infections these
infections are a major cause of death
around the world
one of the most common ways these
bacteria get passed from person to
person is through lack of proper hand
hygiene when people don't clean their
hands they can transfer microbes from
one patient to another or from one part
of the body to another on the same
patient there are four common types of
healthcare associated infections a
surgical wound infection can result when
bacteria get into your incision and
spread through your tissues leading to
infection a urinary tract infection can
occur when you have a catheter in your
bladder which is a tube used to drain
your urine bacteria can enter your
urinary system on the catheter enabling
the bacteria to travel into your bladder
where they can grow a bloodstream
infection can occur when you have a
central line in your vein which is a
slender tube used to deliver fluids or
medications into a large vein near your
heart bacteria can enter the skin around
the insertion site or directly into your
bloodstream where they can cause
infection
pneumonia can result when you are on a
ventilator or breathing machine bacteria
can enter your throat while you are
being placed on the ventilator then you
may inhale the bacteria into your lungs
leading to infection that can cause
pneumonia
hand hygiene a simple low-cost and
effective procedure is the single most
important method of preventing
healthcare-associated infections all
people in health care facilities
including patients visitors and medical
personnel can help prevent these
infections by cleaning their hands
frequently hand hygiene can be performed
with soap and running water for 40 to 60
seconds or by thoroughly rubbing on an
alcohol-based hand sanitizer for 20 to
30 seconds if you are receiving health
care you are part of the health care
team and you should make sure that
everyone who comes into contact with you
cleans their hands